I don't know if I could tell you
anything about what car come on I know
it's a hidden nation what are you
talking about maybe I can just a little
bit it's a beautiful place
if you get vacation in Wakanda it will
be one of the best spots to go to but
you can not so moving on ooh that's a
Cheshire right she plays tech genius
Cherie and knows everything about what
conda's the most valuable resource how
come that has a rare metal cord by
bringing our country runs on it how is
this sari today clients nice so we've
helped out some superheroes in the past
such as Captain America
he has vibranium in his huge get this
hollow faces some dangerous foes but
luckily he's got some serious backup I'm
here with the Peter Nyong'o who plays in
the Kia can you tell me a little bit
about her
well Makia is an undercover spy she
takes people about any way she can I got
into a disagreement made a bit of a mess
it's look he afraid of anything nothing
she won't admit to hate to do a Marvel
fight see I know who can help you follow
me
[Music]
we'll teach you up today as a sacrifice
though think I got this except remember
surfers don't try this out
the grips his wrist wrap underneath is
on and get a tight grip here take that
right leg and pull to your side that's
it pull them without way yeah no just go
for it
[Music]
there you go Marvel Studios black
panther hits theaters February 16 your
answer that is quite the entourage
show that MA
now that we have your attention
Black Panthers tickets now everybody
there's a whole bunch of Black Panther
to break down I was originally gonna do
some Avengers too but there's so much
black panther I'll see if I can work it
in at the end of the video this gives us
like a really good look at what's going
on in sharees lab how they weave the
vibranium into their clothing so if
you're finding me for the first time be
sure to subscribe to get all the videos
we're within like a couple weeks of
black panther dropping meaning that
there will be more infinity war footage
coming really soon and we've even
started to get some new ant-man and the
wasp but we won't have footage for that
for probably a little while I'll try to
explain that stuff at the end of the
video there's just a lot of really cool
Marvel stuff happening right now
so if you were bummed out before [ __ ] is
on and there is an Infinity Gauntlet
giveaway - I'll name a new winner at the
end of this so starting with the first
part - you get it a little bit of
voiceover as he's sort of explaining the
secrets of Wakanda that's kind of what
this trailer is about like revealing
some of the extra cool technology which
is probably one of the best parts of the
film you know great action great actors
great acting great story but a big part
of new Marvel movies them spending you
know 150 million dollars on these movies
is seeing all the cool toys that they'll
bring back around an upgrade for
infinity war so if you couldn't tell
when he's talking to that girl who's
interviewing him at the beginning that's
actually the same place where he's
confronting kill monger only it's all on
fire in the trailer which seems like it
might be their version of the Necropolis
because you have the Panther statues it
just looks very ceremonial compared to a
place like sharees lab which is all
about technology research the future so
you get a lot of that with these
different scenes in different places in
Wakanda some of them are steeped in
traditions some people are all about the
past some people are all about the
future
so as kill monger is talking about
Wakanda it powers their city they weave
it into their clothing you see this 3d
vibranium printer print out adora milosh
a uniform in weaponry so we know that
all black panther's technology that he
uses himself is made out of vibranium
and obviously all their metal weaponry
is vibranium like Captain America's
shield like she talks about oh there are
other people that take advantage of
vibranium - like Captain America's
shield but that extra special layer that
you learn about in this film is about
how they can weave it into everything
like it all goes by
to that Ultron joke where he talks about
how dumb humans are because the most
advanced malleable metal on the planet
and they turn it into a frisbee but what
they don't say in the trailer but you do
kind of see it happening as the suit is
forming around him you actually see what
it looks like it's you know that this
energy is it's sort of connecting itself
all across his body is that vibranium as
an element isn't just the strongest
metal on the earth it's also the best
conductor of electricity so like a lot
of the world's computers are based on
silicon technology replacing silicon
with vibranium would be the quantum leap
in technology just daily lives of normal
people forget about weaponry just like
the daily things that you use as you go
about your business but you had to
imagine that Iron Man is just salivating
at the thought of getting his hands on
this we haven't really picked up with
Iron Man in a while so we really only
get reaction shots from him in the
Infinity war trailer but I'm guessing
that since the events of Civil War
he started to get more information about
what's going on in Wakanda
but because the Black Panther movie is
all about revealing that to the world it
will get some sort of Avengers tag at
the end I'm guessing that he doesn't
actually learn the fullness of what's
going on in Wakanda till infinity war
just because it seems like Sheree is
gonna be a pretty critical character
because they're gonna need everything
they can to defeat Thanos in vibranium
is probably gonna be a big part of that
like oh you know we need to upgrade our
technology okay well I have something
that can help us do that they also
finally added the CG to sharees
gauntlets so we see that they fire
blasts we don't know what kind of energy
this is but assume these are just
vibranium gauntlets give me all of your
barfing cat jokes remember how they did
all those parodies Civil War promos I
can see an infinity war version of this
where Robert Downey jr. just walks out
onto the stage holding two cats in his
hands the big chase scene with all those
Alexis's which which is basically an ad
for Lexus because there the car that
bought the integration on that movie the
way that Audi buys integrations on Iron
Man movies like Captain America Civil
War that's why Iron Man always drives an
Audi ever since the first film so if you
wonder why 90% of the vehicles that you
see in the Black Panther movie are all
made by Lexus that's why but you just
had to love Danai gurira scenes in this
she's a total badass
schon is a total badass so no surprise
that Danai gurira in black panther as
head of the dorm elijah is a total
badass
but in that separate scene before black
panther drops down into the jungle she
says guns so primitive it's not
connected to this big claw chase scene
but it's all about them hyping up the
idea that their weaponry even though it
seems more primitive is actually much
more advanced because it's all made of
vibranium she hooks the spear at them as
she's flying through midair and if you
couldn't tell because the footage is
really dark and it's moving really
quickly the spear being vibranium sticks
in the ground so deeply and it's so
strong that it's what flips that giant
car over so this is all part of that
claw chase scene before they capture him
before these scenes with Everett Ross so
I think this is relatively early in the
film pretty much all the chase scenes
you've been seeing these fight scenes in
the casino they're all from South Korea
I'm guessing this is where Stan Lee's
cameo is going to be he said it wasn't
quite as exciting as some of his other
movies like in guardians of the galaxy
where he gets to hang out with the
watchers early guess is that he's gonna
be one of these casino patrons while all
this is going on just all this craziness
around him but let me know in the
comments what is your guess for what
Stan Lee's cameo is going to be during
Black Panther if he's confirmed that
it's not gonna be quite as exciting as
some of his other cameos there is the
new round of that Infinity Gauntlet
giveaway all you have to do to enter
just be subscriber and leave a comment
on the video congratulations to the
winner from my last video Alan padilha
please private message me so I can get
your contact details click here for more
infantry war and click here for my Black
Lightning
Episode one video thank you so much for
watching everybody stay awesome I'll see
you guys tonight
[Music]